I just came across the sales pitch for store based probiotics. Their claim was
that regular probiotics are 99% destroyed by your stomach acid and never reach
your smaller testant to do anything for you. But the compounds that are
spore based do survive stomach acid and go on to do their work. Have you ever
heard of this? Is this a real thing? So there are benefits to store based
probiotics for several reasons. It does survive stomach acid better. That
figure that 99% of other probiotics are destroyed in the stomach acid is
correct. So that is wrong sales pitch claim right there. I don't think you need
everybody needs spore based probiotics. Matter of fact, good companies that are
selling probiotics that have spore based and nuns, spore based probiotics
typically recommend because the research recommends that you don't need to
be on spore based probiotics indefinitely. So if you're taking a probiotic daily,
you might want to take spore base. This is why my whole idea is to alternate your
probiotics so that you're changing even companies that you're getting them from
so that you're getting different varieties, grown different in different batches
and it can have benefits that way. So I think spore based probiotics are great.
We use ortho molecular spore based probiotics. We use mega spore, spore based
probiotics. They are more stable. They are more expensive though. You don't need to
take spore based probiotics on a regular basis. Maybe go through a model spore based probiotics,
then switch to a different non spore based probiotic, then switch to a different probiotic.
That's why we have multiple different probiotics on our store and I have said over and over
together. I think there's benefit to rotating your probiotics.